what what's the process of coming up
with a new mask look like do you have
like uh like a special effects guy that
like
sometimes man i mean sometimes we have
like a vision in our head like clown is
really good at it because he's an artist
so he'll
kind of go somewhere gnarly and be like
okay i've got this image and then we'll
have you know outside people kind of
help us create it
but then there's sometimes where you're
just like you know what i don't have a
a real vision but i have an idea and you
talk
through it
with
you know like a visual app like a visual
arts guy or you know like a visual
effects guy and they will create it for
you and then you look at it and you go i
like this change this and blah blah blah
blah you whittle it down until you get
to something that's really rad you know
my new mask is gonna [ __ ] scare kids
so
gnarly dude it's really uncomfortable it
freaked my wife out she won't look at it
and she loves
loves crazy [ __ ] like that she's just
like that's really bothering me you put
that picture away and i'm like yeah this
one and she just couldn't
that you went through with the uh when
they had to go through the cover your
nose right right i mean for like
prosthetics like uh when they turned us
all into old men for jackass you
it's a claustrophobic [ __ ] thing dude
oh dude i fall asleep
[Laughter]
i told you there's something wrong with
me but i mean it's like for real like
you just i've seriously fallen asleep
before where i'm just you know they have
to kind of give me a nudge because if i
go down like that i'm going to ruin them
because they took it off steve he was
like
i almost lost it in there dude like two
more minutes you know like it's tough
man especially the first time when we
did it for the jackass the movie my nose
was all blocked up with cocaine all you
can breathe through your [ __ ] nose i
could barely breathe through it because
there was so much [ __ ] blow in there
i was [ __ ] like not okay wow
i guess i'm glad that i waited you know
yeah
i stopped doing bloating yeah no kidding
i mean people don't realize how much you
go through just to get that mask
i think it's just a mask that you go on
but it's a process
pretty much so yeah i know and
completely changing the look that had to
have been [ __ ] scary man like where
you're like oh okay now i'm gonna
trash this this look that that uh it was
the first one with the one that all the
dreads and stuff
yeah yeah yeah and and then you come
back
well with the first my my mask
the first two albums were very similar
like the the iowa mask was essentially
the same kind of vibe but i had changed
the
the uh the aesthetic a little bit still
had the dreads it was the original dread
i kept those
but then we got to
volume three and i just went man you
know what i want to change this up and
some of the guys in the band had changed
theirs completely on iowa and i was like
well they can get away with it
you know i'm gonna try something
different i did what was called what we
called the the the the football mask
because it it was kind of cut like this
and then it had um
sticks
can i just tell you how [ __ ] up my new
tour is it's completely multimedia
legitimately x-rated there's legal
waivers all over the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and it's all the stuff i wasn't
allowed to do on jackass so get to my
[ __ ] website stevo.com and get your
tickets man especially with this movie
coming out dude they're all gonna sell
dude so hurry up while you can get seats